[Musique]
les sénatoriales qui auront lieu le
dimanche 24 septembre prochain tous les
jours on vous emmène suivre la campagne
à travers nos département aujourd'hui
vous l'avez vu direction le pas de calé
droite et gauche sont divisés ce qui
pourrait profiter au rassemblement
national Jonathan dupriaz et Samia de
chir allez prenez place B j'ai pas vu
j'ai pas vu ma deuxème de liste ils
mettent en avant l'expérience le
jean-fançis RIN tête de liste à droite
et Amel ger numéro 2 pour l'UDI vise de
sièges dans le Pas de Calais ce jour-là
épaulé par Xavier Bertrand ils
présentent leur projet à 90 grands
électeurs principal à tout leur
appartenance à la majorité sénatoriale
avant une année chargée au Parlement on
va redémarrer la session parlementaire
avec des textes très lourds sur
l'immigration sur la fin de vie qui sont
des textes où vous avez besoin d'avoir
des gens qui sont sur de jambes qui on
l'assise prête mais Jean-François rappin
c'est la campagne moins lisible qu'il y
a 6 ans du fait d'un paysage politique
éclaté 4000 grands électeurs éparpillés
dans 890 communes dont les 2 tiers sont
sans étiquette politique difficile donc
de se hasarder à des pronostics quand
vous me demandez si effectivement c'est
la même chose qu'il a 6 ans non j'ai pas
l'impression on est quand même dans une
campagne beaucoup plus de proximité
beaucoup plus de de corps à corp et et
avec au compteur beaucoup de qui
s'affiche parce que les gens nous
demandent de la proximité face à
Jean-François Rapin se dresse un
obstacle au centre la liste modème
renaissance de Jean-Marie vanlerenberg à
84 ans le doyen du Sénat ancien maire
d'aras a décidé de se relancer
rassurez-vous moi aussi je pensais ne
pas jouer les prolongations et puis ben
on est venu me solliciter des maires
important je suis à la tête d'un
commando al mon intention c'est pas de
prolonger indéfiniment il est évident
mais de les entraîner je connais
évidemment bien le département tu vas
bien le duo qui table sur son expérience
des affaires sociales espère aussi faire
la différence grâce à sa numéro 2
Brigitte bourguignon ancienne ministre
de la Santé macroniste issue du PS mais
la bataille s'annonce rude au vu des
divisions de la droite et du centre car
en plus d'une liste LR une autre réputée
proche du mouvement horizon s'est lancé
dans la course nous on connaît le risque
ici je je trouve toujours dommage que
certains nai toujours pas compris dans
notre département il était plus qu'utile
d'agir ensemble que de partir dispersé
parce qu'on sait très bien à qui profite
toujours la dispersion ces divisions
pourrai aider Christopher Zurek à faire
son entrée au Sénat à 38 ans le candidat
proche de Marine Le Pen représente l'une
des meilleures chances du RN de faire
son comeback au Palais du Luxembourg ça
met pas vraiment l'impression parce que
je fais ma je fais mon petit bonhomme de
Chevin entre guillemets je une vraie
motivation en revanche évidemment à ce
que le RN revienne au Sénat parce que je
pense qu'il y a un vrai manque
aujourd'hui le premier adjoint à la
mairie d'éninbaaumont se dit candidat du
réel et mise sur une campagne rurale
discrète pour séduire les quelques 650
mares sans étiquette du département moi
je fais des rendez-vous individuels avec
les Mair parce que je pense aussi que
c'est ce qu'ils attendent de nous
c'estàd un contact direct beaucoup de mè
me disent parfois soit qu'ils ont pas
forcément beaucoup vu le sénateur durant
les six dernières années soit que de
manière générale ils se sentent un peu
un peu abandonnés moi je j'ai envie de
leur prêter aussi une oreille à une voix
si vous voulez euh
la communiste CTIA poursopoli veut
justement être l'un des rempards au RN
et notamment dans le bassin minier où
l'extrême droite possède Sébastion la
sénatrice capitalise sur son expérience
à la commission des affaires sociales du
Sénat et sa forte présence sur le
terrain avec plus de 600 communes
visitées durant son mandat moi je ne
suis pas juste dans une période
électorale ça fait 5 ans que je labour
le terrain en tant que sénatrice ça a
fait depuis 2000 2014 oui je labour pour
le bassin minier pour la rénovation et
donc une élection pour moi ne va pas
changer les choses la tête de liste PCF
mise aussi sur l'ouverture avec le
divers gauche Jean-Pierre corbiset en
numéro 2 sur sa liste nous nous sommes
retrouvés sur la réforme des retraites
nous nous sommes retrouvés sur le projet
de loi des secrétaires de mairie nous
nous retrouvons sur la Zane finalement
on s'est dit cunir nos force pour le
département avec une liste qui
représente l'ensemble du département
parce que nous avons des colistiers qui
sont sur l'ensemble du département une
liste donc départementale j'insiste sur
ça unie et donc tout naturellement nous
avons décidé de travailler ensemble en
l'absence d'une liste d'union de la
gauche les socialistes se sont lancés
seuls dans la bataille avec Jérôme Daras
premier adjoint de la mairie de Liévin
et ancien fonctionnaire territorial et
la sénatrice sortante Sabine Vang sous
la bannière MRC j'ai déjà l'expérience
d'un mandat ça change la physionomie de
la de la campne AG parce qu'on a on a
des choses à dire sur notre bilan et on
a aussi un recul le recul nécessaire
pour pouvoir parler au maire voilà merci
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation si le
PS peut tabler sur ses bons résultats
aux dernières municipales pour faire au
moins un siège le risque d'éparpillement
est grand en plus des communistes LFI et
les écologistes conduisent eux aussi des
listes concurrentes là le choix été fait
pour ces élections sénatoriales de
partir en liste séparé parce que nous
estimions que cela serait plus clair
vis-à-vis des grands électeurs nous nous
sommes pour la clarté nous nous sommes
une liste socialiste citoyenne affirmé
comme tel nous sommes les représentants
de la gauche des solutions avec H listes
au total et de nombreuses divisions
entre la droite le centre et la gauche
et avec un RN en embuscade l'élection du
24 septembre promet d'être scruté dans
le P decalais et justement regarde
l'ensemble des listes candidates dans ce
département du pcal les SEP sièges sont
à pourvoir dans le département Charles
on l'a vu droite et gauche en N dispersé
est-ce que ça peut profiter au
rassemblement national sur les terres de
Marine Le Pen écoutez c'est vrai que là
c'est le département qui est le
département parmi tous ceux qui sont en
jeu ce ce weekend sur lequel le
rassemblement national compte pour faire
un
retour au Sénat après je ne sais pas si
la division peut jouer par le mode de
scrutin fait que
bon ce qui est sûr c'est que la parti é
de la candidature du du rassemblement
national dans ce département ils ont ils
ont choisi donc Christopher suzrek qui
est tête de liste qui c'est un profil
qui est intéressant parce qu'il est
premier adjoint desinbaumon qui est la
la mairie un peu historique du du
rassemblement national qui a travaillé
beaucoup avec les élus locaux aux
alentours et et finalement c'est un
profil qui est assez rare au
rassemblement national c'est-à-dire que
quelqu'un qui qui est en contact avec
avec avec le territoire avec les élus
ces différentes strates ce qui jusque-
là était est un peu le le handicap du
rassemblement national c'est il y a
beaucoup de candidats mais qui se
présentent sur étiquette et qui joue à à
fond sur l'image qu' le rassemblement
national c'est quelque chose qui peut
marcher très très bien à des élections
comme les législatives on l'a vu la
dernière fois mais pour des sénatoriales
ça ne marche pas parce que comme les
électeurs ne sont pas des électeurs
lambda mais à plus de 90 % des en fait
des élus municipaux
euh ce qui comp il faut avoir un une
implantation locale c'est il faut de
l'implantation locale il faut du du
terrain du contact direct et et c'est
vrai
que si il y a retour du rassemblement
national au Sénat ça se fera très
certainement dans ce département il y a
pas d'élus actuellement il y en avait
mais à Stéphane Ravier est passé chez
chez reconquête Gérard Larché il dit
s'attendre à une poussée du
rassemblement national il parlait de 5 à
10 sièges est-ce que le rassemblement
national sera en mesure de faire autant
pour vous Michel non je ne pense pas
parce que effectivement pour toutes les
raisons que qu'on on a évoqué euh le le
sénatorial c'est une machine à fabriquer
des notables euh donc c'est c'est sur la
base de notable qui existe déjà donc qui
peuvent voter pour eux donc ça va être
plutôt je dirais euh une forme de test
pour voir quelle est l'attractivité et
les transferts de voix sur un candidat
donc RN qui peut permettre de commencer
à mesurer ce qui se passera pour les
prochaines élections et en particulier
pour 2027 pour pour le RN cette cette
élection
en fait ça les intéresse peu ils
considèrent que c'est pas vraiment leur
élection qu'ils sont pas justement pour
ça en situation mais ça peut par effet
de surprise ça paraît par effet à cause
des divisions il peut y avoir sans
combattre par effet mécanique donc des
sièges et des élections et ça de ce
point de vuel ils pourront ensuite dire
et plastronner regarder formidable c'est
un un signal voilà mais en réalité c'est
pas pour l'instant c'est pas leur
élection c'est même cette sénatorial
vont permettre de commencer à regarder
un peu quelle armature politique est en
train de se tisser pour l'élection 2027
un mot Alex oui effectivement quand on
écoute le discours de rentrée de Marine
Le Pen à a baumon elle ne cite pas les
élections sénatoriales elle est
concentrée sur les élections européennes
en juin 2024 alors effectivement ça va
être compliqué de faire un bon score
pour le rassemblement national au
sénatorial entre 5 et 10 sénateurs c'est
c'est ce qui se dit mais attention he
s'ils vont au-delà de 10 sénateurs c'est
la limite pour avoir un groupe un
politique et si jamais le RN a du un
groupe politique au Sénat ce serait
quand même à distinguer ça ferait du
temps de parole pour ces élus donc ce
sera assez notable effectivement elle en
a pas parlé dans son discours de rentrée
mais elle en avait parlé dans son
discours de rentrée en septembre dernier
elle avait appelé les élus locaux pour
pousser les sellateurs du rassemblement
national ça veut dire que depuis elle a
lâché cette élection ça ça n'intéresse
pas le rassemblement national comme le
dit mckel non c'est pas ça c'est que
c'est des élections en fait c'est des
campagnes au long cours qui sont près
des élus locaux donc là pour un discours
de rentrée où le le public en fait des
électeurs lambda ou voilà elle donne le
ton d'une campagne nationale euh
finalement les sénatoriales sont déjà un
peu joué c'est est-ce que les listes ont
déjà fait le travail sur le terrain ou
non après je suis d'accord elle a
toujours été très mezov sur les
sénatoriales on peut elle s'est impliqué
dans cette campagne ou peut on peut
quand même reconnaître qu'il y a un
petit un petit enfin il y a un peu de
mouvement ça ça va un peu mieux parce en
2014 elle appelé à la suppression du
Sénat donc si vous voulez donc voilà euh
maintenant c'est plus le cas elle au
moins dans les mots elle dit qu'elle
qu'elle qu'elle espère que son parti va
s'y implanter on verra bien dimanche
est-ce qu'elle s'est imp est-ce qu'elle
s'est non elle s'est pas mobilisé dans
cette campagne c'est vraiment du comme
c'est une campagne vraiment de de
terrain de proximité c'est les
différentes têtes de List qui ont fait
le travail on va continuer à parler du
rassemblement national et et de son
président Alex est-ce qu'il peut faire
de l'ombre à Marine Le Pen Jordan
Bardella mais en tout cas Jordane
Bardella a était sur le devant de la
scène médiatique cet été puisque c'est
lui qui est allé parler à Emmanuel
Macron lors des des rencontres de
Saint-Denis entre le Président de la
République et les chefs de partis au
sein de la majorité présidentielle et
bien on raconte même qu'Emmanuel Macron
a été agréablement surpris par le jeune
chef du rassemblement national en
trouvant son propos je cite précis clair
pertinent alors c'est peut-être une
stratégie macronist pour essayer de
diviser Jordane Bardella et Marine Le
Pen et puis début juillet il était aussi
très mobilisé dans les médias pendant
les les émeut pour demander un surceut
d'autorité au gouvernement et puis pour
réagir à la polémique de laba à l'école
en C de rentrée il a également lancé sa
campagne comme tête de liste
rassemblement national aux élections
européennes et il est actuellement le
favori des sondages dans ce scrutin
alors oui Jordan Bardella est dans une
bonne dynamique mais il ne fait pas
encore de l'ombre à Marine Le Pen qui
elle aussi a une très forte popularité
mais est-ce que dans ses prises de
parooles il commence à s'émanciper de
Marine Le Pen alors vu de loin pas
vraiment il reste plutôt loyal à Marine
Le Pen qui qui est son mentor en
politique mais quand on regarde dans le
détail il y a quand même une dissonance
notamment sa dernière interview donné au
journal Le Figaro je le cite une
répartition des rôles s'est installé
avec Marine Le Pen depuis 2019 et
peut-être un peu plus depuis la
présidentielle de 2022 ce duo est
complémentaire aujourd'hui il est de ma
responsabilité alors que Marine Le Pen
préside notre groupe à l'Assemblée
nationale et bien de faire en sorte que
le rassemblé national remporte ses
élections européennes alors il parle
d'un duo complémentaire finalement il se
met un petit peu au même niveau que
Marine Le Pen et la renvoie à son poste
de présidente de groupe parlementaire et
quand on observe les leur discours
politique et bien il y a deux lignes qui
commencent à diverger un petit peu en
témoigne leur déclarations de rentrée
d'abord Marine Le Pen un dimanche
dernier à eninbumont et bien elle tenait
un discours très social sur l'école la
jeunesse on l'écoute les jeunes Français
étudiants ou jeunes actifs sont
désormais massivement convaincus qu'ils
n'accéderont pas au même niveau de vie
que leurs parents ils ont subi
l'effondrement de l'école de la
République et de l'enseignement
supérieur ur un effondrement qui est le
premier responsable du déclassement des
générations futures voilà un discours
social sur la jeunesse pour Marine Le
Pen et pour Jordane Bardella on était
sur un vrai discours droitier notamment
avec la volonté de remettre de
l'autorité à l'école on va l'écouter
c'était dimanche dernier sur France 3
nous souhaitons notamment qu'il y ait un
dispositif de sanction planchée
c'està-dire de sanction minimales qui
puissent s'appliquer pour les élèves
perturbateurs dans les conseils de
discipline pour éviter parce que bien
souvent la décision du personnel
éducatif est un peu minorée comp tenu
des pressions qu'il subissent je pense
qu'il faut responsabiliser les parents
que ce soit sur la violence ou sur les
revendications politico-rigieuses par la
suspension des allocations familiales en
cas de troubles répétés et en cas de
trouble récidivés dans l'enceinte de
l'établissement scolaire c'est un peu
l'esprit d'ailleurs de la loi Coti qui
avait été votée en 2010 abrogé par la
gauche en 2012 voilà gros clin d'œil de
Jordane Bardella Eric Coti le président
du Rassemblement national qui s'adresse
clairement aux électorats de droite
pendant cette campagne des élections
européennes car il sera en concurrence
avec la liste DLR également avec la
liste reconquête emmenée par Marion
maréchal la niaise de Marine Le Pen qui
elle ne cache pas son projet d'unir les
différents partis de droite et
d'ailleurs elle tend la main à Jordan
Bardella c'était cette semaine sur
France 2 je la cite si Jordane Bardella
aujourd'hui a changé d'avis et évolué et
qu'il est prêt à travailler et à se
mettre autour de la table avec des gens
de LR avec reconquête moi j'ai envie de
dire allons-y parlons-en pour l'instant
il est bien sûr h de question pour le
rassemblement national de faire une
alliance avec reconquête on va parler de
reconquête Michel mais d'abord jeardan
bardellaa il sera loyal à Marine Le Pen
ou c'est aujourd'hui son plus grand
danger non il est un danger en rien pour
Marine Le Pen il est beaucoup trop jeune
il est pas il est pas ancré sur le
terrain il faut quand même rappeler
qu'il n'a jamais tenu un mandat il n'a
jamais au fond présider ou travailler
dans une collectivité donc il a encore
beaucoup de je dirais de chemins à
parcourir ir même si effectivement on
devine une une appétence et une forme de
virtuosité pour le pour pour la pour
l'action politique ça de ce point de vue
là c'est c'est indéniable mais il faut
quand même on poursuit toujours ce
mantrra de l'Union ou de la division qui
peut faire donc qui est déterminant dans
une élection en 1995 la droite a gagné
parce qu'elle a été divisée parce que
entre Baladur et Chirac ça ratisé
beaucoup plus large et ça a permis
ensuite de pouvoir de pouvoir gagner
donc le quand on on voit le la matrice
qui est posée sur la comp arité je pense
qu'il faut c'est sincère enfin je pense
que ça c'est effectivement ça fonctionne
en tout cas à date ça fonctionne et
c'est une une mécanique qui permet
effectivement de ratisser plus large à
la fois le pôle social et le pôle plus
droitier identitaire que l'on connaît
chez Bardella et au final ça explique
aussi l'assise du RN dans le pays qui ne
se dém pas malgré les jeux d'apprentis
sorciers qui ne trompent personne du
côté de l'Élysée donc c'est c'est un
vrai duo il c'est pas un duel bardela Le
Pen c'est ça en fait il y a deux
lectures possibles c'estàd ce que ce que
vous voyez comme peut-être des prémises
de dissension parce qu'il y a des
différences de discours so en effet on
est face à une Marine Le Pen qui a un
discours qu'on connaît qui est social et
un Jordan Bordella qui commence à
s'émanciper avec une découverte de ligne
idéologique plus identitaire soit on se
dit ok il y a fait il y a un nouveau il
y a un nouveau joueur dans le dans le
jeu qui s'appelle reconquête et que
peut-être c'est la stratégie du rat
c'est-à-dire que Marine Le Pen qui est
fidèle à elle-même et qui concertaé avec
Jordan Bardella qui en fait exprime une
autre sensibilité pour pouvoir en effet
ratisser plus large moi je pense que
c'est ce en effet ce second scénario qui
a privilégié pour le moment Jordan
Bardella a eu un parcours d'une
météorite au sein du rassemblement
national et ce parcours il le doit à une
seule personne qui est Marine Le Pen qui
le nomme tête de liste aux européenes en
2019 Marine Le Pen qui l'impose en
président par intérim du parti en 2021
Marine Le Pen qui fait campagne pour lui
pour qu'il devienne président président
du Rassemblement national il y a un an
Marine Le Pen si vous voulez il y a un
moment alors évidemment on a on respecte
pas toujours ses pères en politique
c'est c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
il est encore un peu tôt dans l'histoire
pour voir des des des véléités de de
tuer la mer là chez Jordan B oui il en
est pas encore effectivement à ce stade
moi ce ce qui me frappe surtout c'est le
le le le propos de Jordan bardellaa
parce qu'on regarde toujours du côté de
reconquête mais je pense que reconquête
n'est pas une force aussi importante que
cela on l'a vu hein on voit bien que
c'est ça'est voilà c'est assez faible
compris avec Marion maréchal elle pour
elle fera pas de l'ombre à Jordan bel
européen j'ai pas l'impression que
l'arrivée de Marion maréchal à la tête
de liste provoqué un momentum politique
mais on verra bien on est qu'au début de
la campagne ce qui me m'interpelle
surtout c'est l'appel de pas caché du
tout de jardin bardellaa de dire il faut
recréer l'UMP et ça je pense que c'est
un c'est beaucoup plus intéressant pour
le RN d'avoir quelqu'un qui peut aller
attirer les voix de de LR dans les
circonscriptions pour pour former un
socle majoritaire et effectivement être
capable de parler à cette droite à
laquelle Marine Le Pen a effectivement
depuis toujours une difficulté à
s'adresser et ça Jordan Bardella il peut
le faire reconquête c'est pas un sujet
au rassemblement national il vise les LR
en fait c'est pas vraiment un sujet
parce quand on regarde en effet on est
très tôt dans la campagne donc c'est
mais mais quand on regarde un peu le
comment se dessine un peu les les
prochaines européenne de juin il y a
deux matchs dans le match vous avez la
Ligue 1 donc entre Jordan Bardella le
rassemblement national et la liste
d'Emmanuel Macron et puis il y a la
Ligue 2 qui est le match qui sera
peut-être le plus intéressant d'ailleurs
qui est le match pour la survie entre
les républicains et reconquête c'est
d'ailleurs assez intéressant parce
journalistiquement c'est sympa comme
récit de se dire voilà il va y avoir la
bataille Marion maréchal Jordane
Bardella ils sont de la même génération
et c'est bon en fait je pense que le
match n'aura pas lieu parce que Marion
maréchal va viser les LR pour aspirer en
fait cet électorat et dire il n'y a plus
qu'un seul parti de droite c'est nous
alors que Jordan Bardella il est pas du
tout dans cette logique là il est dans
euh il veut faire des européennes en
fait un référendum antimacron comme en
2019 pour viser derrière ces européennes
la présidentielle donc voilà c'est c'est
un mot de conclusion Michel oui ce qui
est frappant c'est que Jordan Bardella
c'est le gagnant de l'été c'est lui qui
a effectivement été celui qui a été mise
en avance et c lui qui a été intégré en
fait dans l'arc républicain par Emmanuel
Macron à sainten avec un narratif très
particulier où il est revenu sur le lieu
de son enfance et de son et sont ses
études donc de ce point de vue là oui
c'est la personnalité qui émerge on
verra de quelle manière ça pourra donc
que poursuivre se poursuivre ensuite
notamment en juin prochain ouais on
suivra tout ça la campagne ne fait que
commencer hein vous l'avez
dit